hello in this video I will show some of
the benefits the DataPower operation
dashboard also known as d-pod can offer
to your organization first of all this
is the landing page and you see the
system activity device if you device
memory and what can attract your
attention is the system errors as you
can see you have the message but also
the level of severity end that the
device is coming from so the first time
that you connect to D pod that is
probably the first thing that you want
to see let's go quickly through the
dashboards that you have available and
then we will do a specific exercise so
in recent activities you will see the
informations like successful
transactions and errors and errors are
pretty high compared to transactions you
will have the activity of the entire
system the services by request you will
have the system activities and the
service errors are particularly relevant
and we will get back there then in the
analytics page for example we want to
show the ability to show when red stars
took place as you see there were several
stars with their Ursa and some of them
were unexpected
then let's still go ahead and go to the
sources for example you can see the
device usage main memory of that power
so you can have an idea how much memory
for example the system is using and
therefore a predicted that your system
is healthy or not in terms of security
do you have several security issues that
you can search and identify let's take a
look - security violation really quickly
and here is what you get the data power
the time object ain't type and so on
including the message we have an
investigate tab that's where all the
transactions are reported by time and
you can search by time device domain and
so on and you also have the elapsed time
one one important benefit of people is
the ability to analyze the latency in
the explore you can take a look at the
service configuration and to the failed
objects these are objects in initiative
state enable but they are down finally
the reports there are a preset reports
that you can run on the spot or you can
schedule but you can also define yours
now let's go back to our system overview
here and
recent activities and as we said we are
going to take a look to the service
servers these errors are pretty much
evenly distributed in time and you can
see all the filtering that you can do
the payload you can capture but that's
optional and we will check the latest of
these errors only the information that
you get is the data power when it
happened the domain the service the
error was HTTP 500 server error and you
can scroll to the old row message that
compose a transaction till you arrive to
the message that says fairly selfish
back cell connection and you will find
the URL associated and this was just a
brief overview of some of the benefits
we put the heads in captioning in
quickly troubleshooting errors in your
data power install base